hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar downline engineering with
Chris Burke as 9 tips and tricks to
maximize success presented by Laura
Carlton scientific liaison and trainer
at horizon discovery and I'm Daniella
Steele of horizon discovery and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by
horizon discovery before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like at any time
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click on the send button will save
several questions for Laura to answer
during the Q&A session additionally we
have scientists standing by to answer
questions as they come in during the
presentation we will answer as many
questions as we can if there are
questions that we don't get to we'll
send an email response in the coming
days additionally when this presentation
is available for on-demand viewing
questions can still be submitted and
will be routed to Laura and the research
team for an email response
also please notice you will be reviewing
the presentation in the slient window to
enlarge the window click on the two
arrow symbol at the top right hand
corner of the slide if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem through the ask a
question box
continuing education credits are offered
for these before attending this webinar
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits also
check out the other tabs that contain
helpful resources that may answer
questions that will come up during this
webinar
I would now like to introduce our
presenter Laura Carlton who will be
taking us through the tips and tricks
learnt through her years of hands-on
gene editing experience
so Laura Carlton is currently a
scientific liaison and trainer at
horizon discovery Laura has extensive
experience generating cell lines and
model systems both in academia and
industry as well as a wealth of
knowledge from working within a number
of different disciplines including
recombinant protein expression oncology
inflammation and cell death and a Potosi
search Laura gained her PhD from the
National University of Island in Galway
where she studied the pro survival
factor nerve growth factor or NGS in
particular Laura studied the effect of
single point mutations on the affinity
of ngf for its two receptors Laura then
went on to do her postdoctoral work in
Lisbon Portugal
at the lab of Colin Adrian looking at
intracellular trafficking of key
inflammatory mediators to the plasma
membrane
since then Laura has been working with
horizon as part of the gene engineering
team continuing her interest in using
gene engineering and gene modulation
techniques to generate optimal model
systems Laura has worked with many
different cell types as well as many
different gene engineering goals
including knockouts and knock ins of
point mutations and tags all of this
together with her research knowledge
means that Laura has a lot of hands-on
experience in getting to a gene editing
goal fast so now for the presentation
and over to Laura
thank you for that kind introduction
Danny so I'm just going to dive straight
into the learning objectives of this
webinar and what I aim to cover so we
are going to run through important
considerations to make when initiating
your gene engineering projects and these
will include the cell I'm optimization
considerations to take about your gene
target guide choice physician and donor
design and finally we're going to talk
through different screening strategies
and validation techniques that will help
you find and the important resultant
clones what I will be highlighting
throughout this talk are the different
tools and reagents that we actually use
within the cell line engineering
department here in horizon to speed up
this process and to kind of help us
rapidly determine the genotype of our
cell line and this is how I'm going to
also cover how we provide confidence in
in the knockout results with different
secondary models and rescue models
so first we're going to go
two broad detail on the possible
applications of gene engineered cells
the gene engineering is important for
any researcher interested in determining
the mechanism of action of their gene so
using gene engineering we can make a
gene non-functional allowing us to look
at that mechanism of action making a
non-functional gene means that we can
get a better understanding of how that
gene is contributing to its specific
biochemical pathway and this is shown
nicely here in this paper where a gene
is was knocked out and its function was
confirmed with a rescue experiment so
over expressing that gene again
in addition to gene function studies
gene engineering can also be used to
analyze protein protein interactions
gene engineering is essential to look at
endogenous interactions in yourself as
it allows you to tag proteins and to
visualize them or immunoprecipitate them
at their endogenous level and is really
crucial when looking at protein protein
interactions
keen engineering can also be used as a
validation technique where you can check
the reliability of your key research
findings that are obtained maybe with
antibodies or RNA I in addition to this
we can generate research tools using
gene engineering and such as gene tags
as illustrated by this article by Daniel
like lacquer and where he showed how
CRISPR can be used to tag genes in a
really simplified and scalable model and
and freely it's just gene engineering is
just around in many different functions
and its really had an explosion lately
however gene engineering has been around
for many years and this is with zinc
fingers talons and recombinant
adenovirus ademma associated viruses but
there has been this explosion and gene
engineering with the adaptation of
crisper and CRISPR technology so CRISPR
has really made gene engineering less
costly and less time consuming so there
really is no longer - no longer an
excuse to work with a bad model and
that's why we've seen this explosion of
gene engineering research
broke-ass mine so crisper cast mine was
originally described in bacteria as part
of the bacterial immune system and has
evolved it's the bacterial immune system
as it has evolved this mechanism to
defend against genetic parasites so
CRISPR essentially stands for clustered
regular interspaced short palindromic
repeats and these are areas within the
bacterial genome and cast lines down sir
Cass stands for CRISPR associated
protein so these are proteins associated
with these clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats so
this is a bacterial immune defense and
to fight off invading parasites the
bacteria are able to incorporate foreign
DNA from the parasite into specific
locus in their genome in these CRISPR
locusts 'as in their genome the bacteria
then expressed the integrated foreign
DNA in these CRISPR locusts as guide
CRISPR RNAs
these then interact with the Cassadine
protein and then the cast proteins along
with the CRISPR RNAs can make a complex
that combine to and caught the invading
bacterial of virulent pathogen DNA and
it's this ability for the CRISPR
proteins and the surfer the CRISPR
CRISPR RNAs and the cast proteins to
bind to one another and to cut em DNA in
in in a double-stranded fashion that is
the foundation for CRISPR gene
engineering so what essentially it is is
using these cast proteins and these
CRISPR RNAs to cut DNA
you
so Chris precast mine was adapted for
the use in the million cells by
essentially introducing this bacterial
system into mammalian cells generally
speaking the adaptation of Chris Prakash
mind has two forms the first system that
we see is on the left and this has the
caste mine nuclease displayed in blue
this acts as a scissors to cut the DNA
and the caste mine protein is complex
with two small RNAs the crispr RNA often
shortened to CR RNA or crispr RNA and
this is displayed in yellow and the
tracer RNA in purple these small rnas
guide the caste line nuclease to a
specific locus within the genome so the
caste mine can make the desired cut the
next system we'll talk about is this
chimeric single guide RNA so we can have
the system on the right which consists
of the caste 9 nucleus protein and this
chimeric single guide RNA or sgrna where
the crispr RNA and the tracer RNA are
linked together in a single molecule and
throughout this talk I will be using
guide RNA or tRNA as kind of an umbrella
term throughout to cover both of these
two products so both caste mine systems
can be delivered or expressed in
mammalian cells to cause DNA double
strand breaks and there's these double
strand breaks which facilitates gene
engineering so for the gene displayed
here where the purple boxes represent
the exons so the protein coding regions
of that gene we have designed our guide
RNA to bind within exon 3 of that gene
the caste line protein cooks the DNA and
causes a double strand DNA break DNA
double strand breaks breaks within the
cell cause the activation of the DNA
damage repair pathway CRISPR gene
engineering uses the cell's intrinsic
DNA repair machinery to generate the
genotypes and subsequent phenotypes that
we desire
so for a knock out when we want to make
a non-functional gene we get we
regenerate a knock out using CRISPR gene
engineering so we allow these double
strand breaks that have been generated
by the crisp the cast line and the guide
RNA to be repaired by the endogenous
repair machinery of the cell called
monomakh homologous and joining this
repair machinery is quite error-prone
and often results in small insertions
and deletions within the cell and it's
these small inter and deletions that can
cause frame shifts in your protein
coding sequence and results in a
premature stop codon within your within
your gene making a non-functional
protein so it's really just how the cell
repairs this cast line code that
generates these knockin to generate
specific alterations in the gene we
generate what we call a knock in using
CRISPR so we don't want the double
strand breaks in this instance to be
repaired by non-homologous end joining
but by homology directed repair pathway
and this is because it is a much more
specific repair pathway where it uses a
a donor template to repair the DNA so to
increase the likelihood of the cells to
repair their double strand break by
homology directed repair we co transect
cells with a DNA repair template or a
donor this donor has high homology to
our cut DNA and as well as this it
contains the desired mutations such as a
single point mutation ER attack the cell
then uses this donor to repair its DNA
template and so it uses this donor to
repair its DNA and fix the DNA double
strand break it's also because of use
this donor it also allows for the
incorporation of the desired mutations
in this process so because the donor
contains these mutated regions it
incorporates these mutated regions into
that fixed strand of DNA and that's
essentially how CRISPR works
it cuts DNA
and for our knockouts to be generated
you allow that clique to be repaired by
the endogenous cell machinery before a
knock in to be generated you force the
repair of the bat DNA using a donor
template so now that we understand the
basic principles of CRISPR gene
engineering we are going to go through a
typical cell line engineering experiment
so we understand how CRISPR works but
how can we actually get it to work in
our cell lines so if we look at the
CRISPR gene engineering spur experiment
in the cell line from beginning to end
there are a number of pitfalls in this
project and it's awareness of these
pitfalls or risks within this this this
experiment setup that will prepare you
and to help you get that cell line
faster and it's really just
understanding your cell line in the
first instance and knowing you're
targeting reagents so for knockouts the
gene engineering process usually takes
13 to 21 weeks and for the knock in the
project usually takes 18 to 26 weeks the
range is so large and it can be actually
much longer because I've had a gene
engineering experiment that has lasted
over a year and this is because it
depends very much in the cell line that
you will be using and the genes that you
will be targeting so one of the first
crucial steps in a gene engineering
experiment is preparation
so preparation includes your target
reagent design and this can take
anywhere from one day two weeks and
weeks and this depends on your
experiment experience with and CRISPR
gene engineering as well as how
difficult your gene is to target so you
have to take into account a huge number
of considerations before you can even
begin to work with your cell line and we
will go through these in greater detail
later but this can be actually a real
time sink when you are performing your
gene engineering experiments you could
be sitting on your target reagent design
for weeks and weeks
so after designing a perfect perfect
target reagents you now need to initiate
your targeting project so if your cells
are easy to transact and select this can
take about two weeks but if your cells
have poor viability upon transfection
of your targeting reagents or if they
have a very low transaction rate and
therefore have a potentially very low
number of edited cells in their
percentage then it can take much much
longer to grow and select up this
population so this process can take
weeks and weeks and can be an unexpected
time to lay in your Jo gene engineering
experiment so we always do in the gene
engineering department is characterized
our cell lines to make sure that we can
genetically engineer them and be
prepared for these time delays and kind
of hindrances or hindrances to our
research plan who is just all about the
preparation in this area
so once you have your cell lines
transfected and selected you then need
to single cells elute them or perform a
limiting dilution and I've worked with a
number of different cell lines and some
of them just really don't like to be
single cell diluted so you can have a
very low recovery of yourself upon
limiting dilution and this can mean that
you sometimes have to go back and design
a completely new strategy for yourself
after you've realized that they haven't
single cell deluded so it's really
important to be prepared for this and we
always include this in our
characterization procedure which I'll go
into in more detail a bit a little bit
later on
so if your cell line has single cell
diluted and recovered and grown out you
can now expand these cells and check
their genotype to screen for the
phenotype of interest and you can get a
real mix of genotypes with CRISPR gene
engineering and this can make a
screening quite difficult and a very
time-consuming process however I will go
through some of the tools to help you
determine your genotypes faster later on
in this webinar
and finally once you've got your two or
three clones ready for that I have the
genotype of interest and that are ready
for expansion
we just need to expand and Bank these
cells and this can take actually quite a
long time because you're going from
quite a small population of cells may be
in a 96-well plate or 384-well plate to
a pea 175 or a triple-layer flask so
this is actually a longer process than
originally defined disrespect being
aware of these these possible time
delays in your experiment so there
really is a large time variation in
Eugene engineering experiments so it's
about considering all these risks in
your experiment and these are what I'm
going to go through with you today so
that you can find your genotype faster
and get your cell line faster and the
main considerations to take are the
seven displayed on this slide here so
we're going to go into each of these
considerations and what I'm going to
highlight throughout this process are
ways that we in the cell engineering
team kind of minimize the time spent on
each of these steps so that you can
maximize your gene editing success and
these will be tools that horizon have
generated themselves in high scale as
tools that we actually use from online
free online resources
so the first step there was to look at
your cell line so to characterize your
cell line so you want to consider is
your cell line engineer able so
questions you should ask yourself to
determine if your cell line can be
genetically engineered or can I transect
my cell line or can i infect my cell
line can I enrich for the targeted
events can they undergo limiting
dilution to generate clonal populations
and is my cell line homogeneous so for
the transaction I would recommend doing
a small characterization procedure and
this will not only help for your cell
engineering experiment but for all
further experiments with that cell line
we usually try both electroporation and
lipid lateness lipid based methods in
the cell engineering department and here
I've just displayed an example of a cell
line whose transaction efficiency range
from 19% to 78% using different
electroporation conditions and usually
once we have performed this transaction
procedure we use facts are facts cell
sorter to take out any of those GFP
positive populations to see if our cells
can be effectively sorted without any
loss in cell viability so what we have
done here in this experiment in the
bottom is move transfected ourselves
with the fluorescent cast line and we're
going to take down the fluorescent
population out and sort it into into
into a multi well place to see if there
is the cells are viable after sorting
and this will help us determine if we
can get clonal population straight from
sorting as well as if we can get clonal
populations at all however if you don't
have access to a cell sorter you can do
this exact same experiment except you
can transect yourself using an
antibiotic antibiotic selection
the next question you have to ask if
is can my cells undergo limiting
dilution and should I allow myself time
to recover from selection and from kind
of this this rough cell sorting before I
actually apply this additional stress to
them so we usually test a couple of
different limiting dilution techniques
and ourselves the image on the bottom is
just an example of the recovery that I
obtained when i seeded cells this is a
suspension cell line at 0.5 cells per
well in standard media so just a typical
growth media that they use as well as
conditioned media which is 50% media
that the cells have been in for 24 hours
and 50% their standard media and what
you can see and appreciate here is that
you actually am getting better recovery
and better cell outgrowth when I use the
standard media and this is just to
highlight that the conditioned media
isn't always the best way forward and at
some times doing this test can be
extremely informative because I have had
cell lines not grow at all in their
standard media or not grow at all in the
conditioned media and it really is cell
line dependent so it's really good to
just do this test so you're not ending
up with absolutely no clonal populations
or outgrowth on your and $96 384 well
plates and finally the last question I
ask myself is is my culture homogeneous
so in some cases in some different cell
lines
say for example in cardio myocyte cells
you could have some cell lines some some
cells within that that culture that are
actually contracting in other cell lines
you could have semi adherent cell lines
so you might be interested in
maintaining the semi adherence state or
actually selecting a clonal population
that has become 100 percent adherent in
another cell line population you could
have differentiated and undifferentiated
cells so it's just about knowing
throughout your your procedure that
you're not selecting for one of these
different phenotypes or genotypes for
one of these different phenotypes within
your cell lines because you want to be
capturing the whole population and then
finding out later on that because you've
captured those
two different kind of phenotypes in
yourselves that but that that that has
no effect on the gene that you're
knocking out or you're modifying so once
you have characterized your cell line
and found out that it can be genetically
engineered you should start thinking
about your particular gene target your
particular gene that you're interested
in so what is one of the first things
you should think about is what is the
effect of my modification on gene growth
will it be lead lethal to the cell or
decrease the cell viability
well the modification changed my
phenotype and if it will change my
phenotype can I actually select for that
phenotype and is that it is it important
to select the cells before and single
cells eluding them for this phenotype
the next thing you should consider is
what what is the coffee number of my
jeans so we all consider our jeans to be
a copy number of two and that is that
there is two alleles per gene and we can
see this here on the karyotype map on
the right on the right I want to carry a
type map that basically is it's an image
that depicts all the chromosomes in the
cell and in this image on the right you
can see that we have two alleles per
gene so if we just look at the yellow
genes just in the top left hand corner
you can see that there's two genes for
chromosome one there's two chromosomes
are the two chromosomes come some ones
it's two alleles for chromosome one
excuse me and however this is very rare
genotype for your isolated cells in
culture so if you pay attention to
chromosome one in this next insert you
can see in the you can see in the next
cell line in this HeLa cell line you
actually don't have two alleles for
comes on one but you actually have three
and you have a whole host of other genes
and that aren't reminiscent of any other
chromosomes and the bottom of the screen
and this is more of what we have in our
general cell culture in any of these and
cell line adapted and cultures that we
grow as our model systems so it is
really important information to have at
the start of your gene engineering
experiment because it can help you with
your genotyping process and how we
usually detect the different copy
numbers of our genes is we use digital
PCR or snip six analysis
so the next thing you want to consider
is now that you understand that your
gene target and that you understand what
your gene target is that won't increase
the viability of yourself and you know a
copy number it is you want to understand
how they've got multiple transcripts and
what we usually do by test fit to look
at this is we actually do some
bioinformatic analysis using ensembl and
then this can be really easily fun using
ensembl gene cards and what you want to
be looking for is a transcript that is
basically your CCDs verified but you
will understand what what transcript you
want to and target usually it's it's the
is the CCDF and verified protein coding
transcript so the next question is does
my target have any known pseudogenes
and a pseudo gene is an imperfect copy
of a functional gene and this can be
kind of seen as as as incorporated
anywhere within the genome and I can
really interfere with the genotyping and
your targeting so it is important to
understand if your gene target has I
mean and see the genes and all of the
known situ genes can be found in this
link that I have here on pseudogenes org
is really useful information will help
you guys your and target reagent design
later on and the last thing that you
should consider is with my target of any
difficult to amplify regions so just to
have any polities high GC regions or
repeat regions because designing guide
RNA into this region will be very
difficult as well as amplifying up this
region if you want to do any kind of
downstream genotyping
so I talked about the guide but now
we're just going to understand what
makes a good guide and what really is
the important considerations you should
take when designing your guide
essentially a good guide is targeting
the eggs on our interim that you're
interested in so we have different
considerations to make when designing a
guide RNA for a knockout or for a
knockin so for a knockout you want to
have a biter in a targeting the desired
transcript so that's one of the
considerations we took earlier as well
as getting all the splice variants that
are associated with that gene you should
also think about the possibility of of
targeting a functional region within
that gene and whether that transcript
has any alternative start sites that
could cause a truncated protein even if
you if you've edited a upstream of that
and that alternative start site
for not games the main consideration you
want to take is to choose a guide or an
a clip site as close as humanly possible
to the engineering site this will really
increase the likelihood of your and
imaging your modification getting
incorporated into your gene
their general rule for all guide RNAs is
to avoid DNA stretches that contain
repetitive sequences and you have to
wait off the on target and off target
score so you should really be aiming for
a guide RNA that is as low as possible
off target score and a high as possible
on target score so that really is quite
a lot of considerations to take and when
when designing your guide RNA so one of
the other questions you need to consider
is what algorithm to use so there's a
lot of online tools to design your guide
RNAs and we would really recommend that
you use the guide RNA design algorithm
that we've generated in-house and this
is a really powerful algorithm that
takes into all it takes into
consideration all these key
considerations and it's constantly being
updated and it's really well maintained
and we have actually designed
pre-designed crispr RNA and lentiviral
SP RNAs using this algorithm so these
are different guide RNAs that you can
just buy directly off the shelf for your
gene of interest and they're available
for you and I've just left a link to
where you can get more more details on
those guide RNAs but essentially you can
just put your gene of interest into the
search bar and that will bring up all of
the guide RNAs that are of available for
your gene and these are designed to have
these are guaranteed and designed to
have editing so they are guaranteed to
have editing
you
so pre-designed guide RNAs are great for
a knockout but for a knock in the
cleavage site has to be as close as
humanly possible to that area that
alteration site so you will probably
need to design your own guide RNA for
this and as I said we have this design
algorithm available for you to use and
it is really user friendly so this is a
free design tool that we have put on our
website and it helps you choose the most
effective guide RNA for your specific
genomic space you can use this tool to
indicate where you want to make that cut
with CRISPR cast mine and then all the
available guide RNA will come up and
they will be ranked based on the
functionality and specificity I'm not
going to go into too much more detail on
this tool but if you're interested in
using it I have included a link with
more specific information and a really
good how-to video about how to use this
design tool what it really is good at
well curated well-maintained other
algorithm and constantly being updated
and that's good to keep in mind about
using these free online tools so I
through the first four considerations
knowing your cell line your gene target
guide position and guide choice and what
I wanted to highlight to you here is
that if you take advantage of horizons
reagents you can really decrease the
time spent in designing and checking
your ad reagents and more time really
using them because we have already with
our reagents these editor pre-designed
libraries as well as our guide RNA
design tool we have really kind of
minimized the amount of of time that is
required for these these tasks so now
that you have your guide RNA designed
the next consideration to take is their
donor design so for our knockouts you
obviously don't need a donor design
however it is very good idea to think
about at this stage your screening
strategy that you're going to be using
for your knockouts for your knockin you
obviously have to consider a donor
design and there is a number of
considerations to take mainly it is as
I'm going to say again that your guide
RNA cut site is as close as humanly
possible to the nock in location so to
the area that you want to modify another
consideration is that to incorporate a
screening strategy into your targeted
population so this could be a
restriction site or may be a specific
DNA region you can amplify up later on
or if your modification is going to have
a different phenotype you should be
thinking about screening yourselves
based on a phenotype so incorporating
this or thinking about this screening
strategy at this stage is going to be
really well time well well-deserved time
because it will really help you quickly
identify their clones that you will be
enriching for and screening for it later
on I'll have example of different
screenings where it is very clear that a
robust strategy was required for to to
make sure that we did get that cell line
it in the end so another consideration
to think of when designing your donor is
to incorporate silent mutations into the
guide RNA or the pumps
and this will prevent the continued
cutting of the caste mine and enzyme in
your targeted population so another
question is the type of donor that you
plan on using and this can be plasmid or
single strand DNA eligos and I have some
more resources on this in the following
two slides to help you choose between
these two but in general designing a
donor can be quite an error-prone and
time-consuming task especially when
you're first starting out in gene
engineering and I know very well the
dread of ordering and buying the wrong
reagents so to help with this kind of to
streamline this process horizon has
developed a tool to design both all ago
and plasmid DNA donors and to generate
this tool we've applied everything that
we know about proper donor design and
incorporated these rules into a very
easy to use interface so that you can
decrease the stress levels of designing
your donor and decrease the errors that
are often incorporated when when
designing these so I'm just going to run
through really quickly these and I'll go
to donor design and plasma donor design
tool there are really group until
available for you to get more
information on this which I have linked
here will also be at the end of the
presentation in a resources slide but
I'm just going to give you an idea of
what the Allah God honor design can do
for you so all you have to do is to
enter in your gene and your guide RNA
sequence define the type of alteration
you're going to make and then the tool
will generate that proper all ago for
you even incorporating the silent
mutations to prevent that ongoing
cleavage of the caste mine and so for
your plasma donor design tune so we've
split these up because they are
different beasts for the plasmid the
donor designs he'll again very similar
setup it just as before you enter your
gene and your guide RNA information you
define along the gene where you would
like to do your insertion what kind of
modifications you want
to me and the components required for
the plasma donor assembly are designed
for you and then you can just buy them
it's like one click buy so the plasma
donors are particularly good for a knock
in of a fluorescent marker or other
large inserts and here are some other
resources which we have generated in
these links below to help you when
designing your plasma donor and a how-to
video on how to use that design tool and
again these will all be summarized at
the end of the presentation this reduces
the considerations that you have to make
for your CRISPR design experiment even
further so we have kind of streamlined
that donor design process so it's really
decreasing seven considerations down to
three and we generated these tools just
to streamline this process and to make
it quicker so that you're working with
your cell lines quicker so it really
does help to use these tools and to
basically take advantage of the
experience that we have in CRISPR gene
engineering to get your selling faster
so unfortunately we cannot do any of the
screening for you so you will have to
determine your genotype faster using
different screening strategies but the
best thing to do is to incorporate these
into your into the design of the whole
experiment so there are a number of
different ways and which you can screen
yourself but advertising we found that
the best and most robust quick and
cost-effective way of screening is
always PCR based so really looking at
that DNA level so for the knockouts you
can generate a mix of genotypes for your
knockouts and this can be very difficult
to understand however there are a number
of different online tools that we use to
find the genotype of these knockouts in
a really really fast cost-effective way
so in their cell engineering group in
general if we suspect that the targeting
can be really low and we would have been
seeing this the experiment we usually
perform a PCR over that edited area so
over that say exon 3 from the first
example and subject this PCR to t7
digestion
the t7 detects mismatched DNA and
therefore can identify if that cell has
been CRISPR edited so it can identify if
there has been some kind of insertion or
deletion in that area so we usually
perform these on quite a large scale
when we expect that there is a low and
low targeting efficiency in that cell so
if they've had a very low transaction
rate very poor selection and if the gene
is usually quite essential to the cell
line we usually perform these t7 essays
and then we take any of the positive
clones forward so any of the clones that
showed t7 activity forward and then we
subject them to tide and Chris by D
analysis so if we success if we suspect
a reasonable level of editing we take 96
populations forward perform a PCR over
that gene edited gene of interest and we
use these free online tools tight and
crisp ID to help us identify these and
edit a population
so this is an example of crisp ID and
essentially what crisp ID does anti do
is that they deconvolve the mixed races
that we see during gene engineering and
align them against the parental DNA to
find out what is different in these
mixed races so if you take the top
parental DNA you can see that there is
the guide RNA site and the palm side is
just highlighted there for you and then
we look at the mutant clone that I have
generated and we can see here that they
there is a mixed straight trace in and
around the guide RNA coding sites
suggesting that there has been an
incorporation to that DNA so that there
is two different genotypes and now in in
that in that in that gene and then when
we pass the sequencing traces through
Chris by D algorithm what they do is
they spit out the modification that is
in one of the that is in the two alleles
so we can see here that on allele one we
have a six base pair deletion which is
an in-frame deletion and i'm allele 2 we
have a one base pair insertion which is
an out of frame insertion so we have one
allele which is likely to be functional
and one allele that is likely to have a
premature stop codon so it's really
really very quick way of finding out
your real clones your real knockout
clones from your and may be heterozygous
and lock our clones or your homozygous
and homozygous in frame deletion clones
it's really really great tools
so for the knock in the experiments you
should use for you be the genius I've
been striving you strategy you should
use is the one that you've corporated or
designed into your donor design step and
I'm just going to run through a couple
of different knocking strategies that I
have used and these are going to
highlight the need for the robust
screening strategy that we talked about
earlier so I'm just going to show you
DNA gel electrophoresis of two different
screens so the first screen is here
sorry
so the first screen is here and this is
an example where the knockin was smaller
than the wild-type DNA and I took
advantage of this during my screening
strategy and my design specific primers
to amplify up both the wild-type DNA
that is present so this will be the high
molecular weight and the smaller low
molecular weight band which would
signify any of the targeted cells that I
had so in this first screen I screened
800 clones and I in 30 populations which
appear to be positive for my target of
interest and in this second screen I
where is this there in that second
screen I screamed again 800 clones and I
got 162 positive and positive clones for
the my genotype of interest and what is
different in the second screen is that
it is the same cell line but it is
actually a different guide RNA so it
really shows that there are differences
between the different genes and the
different guide RNA designs so it's
really best to take that guesswork out
and use those off-the-shelf guaranteed
edited and reagents
this knock in screening strategy I
designed a primer so that it would only
amplify up the targeted cells so the
primer only identified of when I had
positive incorporation of my donor so in
this example again I screened for
hundred clones actually in this example
and I got fifty four positive
populations which appear to be positive
for my target and in this example I have
one hundred and sixteen positive and the
difference between these two is that it
is the exact same targeting reagents
however it is different cell lines and
it really does show that the different
cell lines they're different ability to
even take up the CRISPR reagents and the
targeting reagents can affect how they
will perform later on
so now that we've screened ourselves
we're going to go on to the validation
and this is there is really no shortcut
to the validation you just just have to
have to do the validation it's very
time-consuming but it is very important
to understand what you'll be working
with so to confirm the clonality of your
cell we in the cell engineering we use
imaging software which can be seen on
the right here
so we can scan the cells all the wells
all the wells that we've done in
limiting dilution in on day zero and
then look at them maybe ten days after
whenever those cells are grown out to
see if they're clonal or not if you
don't have this imaging software you can
also perform single-cell PCRs or you can
perform some topo cloning to make sure
you're getting a good idea of what
different alleles are present in your
DNA mix in your in your clonal
population so if there is a contaminant
wild-type cells in your clonal
population so we usually confirm the
genotype with a suite of different PCRs
as well as looking at the phenotype of
interest we like to identify any
off-target incorporation as well if it
is required and this is just done by
amplifying up those those top off target
hits that where we were notified of we
also confirm if there is no no
contamination of the bacterial cell as
well as the bacterial contamination as
well as the wild-type cell contamination
and confirm that the there has been the
suspected phenotypic changes within the
cell and during the validation procedure
we usually take quite a number of clones
for it and this is what is important
because you want to be making sure that
you're not drawing your results based on
just one gene edited event on one clone
you want to be having two or three
clones that have been generated that
have the this dis knockout or this knock
in so you're not I'm basically looking
at just a clonal event of yourself
confirmed the genotype of your sorry to
confirm the phenotype of interest we
would recommend some Western blots
validation so on the left to confirm
their gene knockout of the selection of
knockout cells we used suite of
antibodies and this was to confirm the
presence of our absence of the protein
of interest because these are knock
itself and the Western block data
confirms the asset absence of the
protein in the knockout cell line and
then this this validates cysteine
engineering event so you can see that on
the knockout of the cells it's the cell
line is basically represented on the top
you can see that on the knockout of that
gene of interest you do not get that
protein band but if you see a bound on
the Western blots and this does not
actually confirm that the protein is
functional and this this is where the
gene editing has not completely
prevented that proteins being being
expressed but it might have generated a
truncated or completely non-functional
form of that protein so
it is really useful to perform
additional studies that demonstrate that
this protein that is functional and you
can do this by maybe looking at some
immunofluorescence of codons for
localization studies of where you expect
that protein to be so on the example of
the writes you can see the presence of
the absence of this knockout protein was
detected using the immunofluorescence in
the wild-type cells you can see the
green staining and in the knockout cells
you cannot see this green staining and
this would indicate that there cells are
knock out for that gene SLC 3o a six so
now that you've generated your perfect
research tool we want to talk about the
additional validation so where you are
validating your findings in a sense so
if you've generated your research tool
you've made your key findings and now it
kind of feels more robust and confidence
in your data you can use the horizon
knockout catalog of cell lines to as an
additional model as a secondary model
for your gene gene engineering firm and
for your hypothesis so we have a huge
amount of experience in in in gene
engineering and this actually comes from
the generation of these ready-made
knockout cell lines as well as from
custom products but we have a knockout
catalog of cell lines which allow you to
increase the confidence in your results
and the catalog contains collections of
knockouts for probing entire pathways
number of clones there are a number of
clones available per knock regime and
the wildfire control is also included
free of charge so you can validate your
results I'm just going to go into a
quick validation study that someone has
performed using these cell lines and
it's just a really nice validation study
where you can see that their difference
between their wild type and the knockout
was really clear and they then rescued
this knockout using over expression but
also validated that a patient mutation
was very important for the loss of
function
when they over express this protein
again using using the patient mutation
so this example involves the role of III
ligases called RF wd3 and in III
ubiquitin ligases are known to have a
role in the DNA damage repair
particularly in homologous recombination
so it is critical for homologous
recombination to repair defects in when
they are subjected to a chemotherapeutic
reagent and here you can see that in the
survival wild-type cells you can see
that the survival of the cell was
completely fine when they were subject
to a chemotherapeutic drug however when
we knock out our fw d 3 in these cells
you can see that the survival of these
cells was decreased massively and then
in contrast to that you can see that
once we overexpress this protein again
you have rescue of the schema side for
the cells are stain resistant to this
chemotherapeutic reagent and what was
validating these researchers finding
within the secondary model was that when
you overexpress
our fw d 3 with these patient mutations
you do not get to survival anymore so
you do get this and kind of lot sell
sell sell death and when applying this
chemotherapeutic reagent
and this is just the list of resources
that I mentioned out but at the end of
the presentation and if there are now
any questions I'd be happy to take them
but over to you Danny
that's great thank you very much Laura
for this really informative presentation
as Laura mentioned we'll now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar and
while we're getting that ready we will
be popping up a couple of questions on
your screen these really are very useful
for so that we can plan for following
webinars and understand what you would
like to be seeing so those questions
actually I think will be coming up later
on after the Q&A but I'd like to remind
you all that you can submit your
questions by typing them into the ask a
question box which is located on the far
left of your screen just type your
question into the box and hit Send we'll
try and answer as many of your questions
as we have time for so I see that a
couple of coming in already and so
should we start with the first question
in the queue which is can you explain a
little bit more about off-target effects
should I be worried and what can I do to
minimize these effects Laura yeah so to
be on the safe side
we kind of have to believe systems that
are important and simple ways to
minimize potential off target effects so
firstly is to use the most up-to-date
sgrna design algorithms and selection of
the guides with low predicted off target
potential this is what I was talking
about in the session of my
considerations to take when designing
your guide RNA so I really would
recommend using guide RNA design
algorithms that are constantly being
updated and curated and that that would
be the obviously our our our design
algorithm we're secondly to kind of
mitigate the possibility of effects of
the off target editing one of the other
things that we suggest people do is
actually to use multiple clones or
multiple different guides when looking
out there
knockos so as I was saying we would take
several clones forward for validation of
our of our several market cones forward
for our validation not just one but
maybe four and we would really test our
hypothesis in those four cell lines
always what we'd recommend or even
ideally use two different guide RNAs for
the EM knockouts and really test you
know multiple clones with multiple
different guide RNAs especially if it is
a key finding or you could even use a
secondary model such as the half one
cell lines
great thank you very much I have another
question and and it says I want to
create a secondary model to confirm my
results can I just repeat the gene
editing in a different cell line or will
I have to change any of the reagents or
protocols what do you think Laura yeah I
thought
every cell line is different and I think
we went through that during the cell
line characterization board
they can they can really vary on how
easy they are to transact or to single
cells I lose and you might have to
screen many more clones for one cell
line in comparison to the other cell
line which is one of those screening
examples that I showed and but the best
thing I could say is to really
characterize your cell line and to make
sure you're using the correct protocols
for that cell line but I would still use
the same reagents because you've already
used and designed those reagents and you
think they're they're great and you've
gotten a cell line using those reagents
but so you already have that's already
known in your experiment but if you want
to then generate the same knockout in a
different cell line I would use those
reagents but use the protocols that are
important for that cell line so use the
protocols that are going to make sure
that you get that cell em in the end so
test their transection their single cell
delusion check if they can recover and
and what them what's the best enrichment
and protocol for use for the cell lines
thanks Laura that's really helpful it's
difficult sometimes to find one thing
that fits all and I think you've been
quite clear here how cell lines differ
from each other and I think it can be
quite a common trap without looking into
those individual protocols okay one more
question then I'm interested in the
ready-made knockout lines to confirm the
findings from my own gene edited cell
line how readily available
are they thanks Laura Marie's I'm glad
you're interested in them but we've um
we've over three thousand ready-made
knockouts cell lines and these are
available for immediate delivery within
like seven days depending on your
shipping constraints in your country but
it's the catalog has and further six
thousand cell lines that can be
manufactured on demand and these are
available within twelve weeks so we just
put these cell lines into our pipeline
and generate them and then they become
available for everybody so we're
continually putting new cell lines new
noon off cows as readymade on available
for our customers so always request the
cell line and it's the cell line that
you're interested in isn't there just
ask our technical support they're great
they will they just want you to get
those yourselves as well so they will
help you find it the best best selling
for you as well
thanks Laura and and before we wrap up I
think we have time for one last question
it concerns validating the final edited
cell line with antibodies it reads I've
edited a frameshift mutation in my cell
line and have confirmed that this is
occurred with Sanger sequencing how come
I'm seeing a band in Western blot I
think you touched on that briefing in
the presentation I know Laura we've
discussed this quite a lot how
unreliable antibodies can be so this can
be a tricky one what do you think Laura
yeah you know we talked about antibodies
all the time me and Danny talked about
antibiotic use all the time but there
it's there are a lot of nonspecific
nature it's a nonspecific nature to
antibodies on the market so it's really
really important to look at at the
antibody that you're buying see if it is
actually validated in knockout selling
because there are a lot of antibodies
out there there are actually validated
in in knockout cell lines or cell lines
that have been modulated to have lower
expression or higher expression I would
always recommend them as well as that if
you do see a band on your Western blot
it doesn't necessarily mean that your
protein is functional it could be that
you you're the epitope up to your
antibody is designed upstream of the
editing event and therefore you're
actually picking up the
kind of the truncated version of your
protein however and it was expressed
however there is a completely
non-functional region after that because
it either has a stop codon or a
completely different amino acid sequence
and there's the nature of caste line
because you're actually just creating a
cut in the gene you're not you're not
completely deleting the gene you're
creating a quote in the gene to make a
premature stop codon that you can get
these kind of different results with
your Western blot but I would always
recommend a functional assay and just to
test a few different antibodies yeah
that's really great Laura thank you very
much so it's been a wonderful
presentation and some great questions
there so thank you very much Laura and
thank you to the audience as well for
your participation and it's always the
audience's questions that really make
these webinars I find so it's great job
well done and I see that there are a few
more questions remain in the in the
queue and if we didn't get to answer
your question today one of our
scientists will respond to you via email
if you have further questions that you
did not submit during the broadcast then
just email those to us at info at
Horizon discovery.com
so that's Horizon discovery one word
okay but before we go I'd like to thank
the lab roots team and Horizon discovery
for underwriting today's educational
webcast and this webcast can be viewed
on demand all the way through December
2018 lab routes will alert you via an
email when it's ready to be replayed on
demand when it's available we encourage
you to share this email with your
colleagues who may also have missed
today's live event and as I mentioned an
exit poll will come up on your screen
and we'd really appreciate your feedback
as it will help us plan for future
webinars so until next time thank you
very much and goodbye everyone bye
everyone